quiero hacer un vídeo aunque sea un
vídeo un poco rápido sobre algo que vas
a ver tarde o temprano en tus clases
estadísticas voy a hablar de la noción
del error de tipo 1 del error de tipo 1
el cual consiste en lo siguiente se
comete un error del tipo 1 en
estadística cuando rechazamos vamos a
escribirlo cuando rechazamos la
hipótesis nula cuando rechazamos la
hipótesis nula a pesar de que es
verdadera en eso consiste el error del
tipo 1 rechazar la hipótesis nula a
pesar de que es verdadera para que nos
quede más clara esta idea vamos a verlo
con un ejemplo y de hecho ahorita que lo
pienso en todos los vídeos que hemos
visto sobre ejemplos de pruebas de
hipótesis
hemos comenzado asumiendo que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera vamos a
escribirlo la hipótesis nula es
verdadera vamos a trabajarlo de una
manera más gráfica esta va a ser mi
distribución si esta es mi distribución
justo en medio se encuentra en algún
punto me me media entonces ésta va a ser
mi media y recuerden que siempre estoy
asumiendo que la hipótesis nula es
muy bien ahora supongamos que yo les doy
una estadística y nosotros tenemos
valores después de esta estadística
valores mucho más grandes o más extremos
que esta estadística
entonces supongamos voy a ponerla justo
por acá entonces yo tengo un cierto
valor justo aquí y supongamos que yo les
digo no se después de este valor va a
existir una probabilidad del 1% de que
ocurra un suceso es decir después de
este valor para valores mayores o
iguales a este valor la probabilidad de
obtener un resultado o un cierto suceso
es del 1 por ciento y después vemos que
esta probabilidad como es tan baja en
este umbral para nosotros se nos ocurre
rechazar la hipótesis nula ese es el
error del tipo 1 aunque si quieren lo
podemos ver de la siguiente manera creo
que esto les va a ayudar a dejar todo
mucho más claro supongamos que tenemos
un umbral del 1% este umbral que tenemos
aquí y además estamos asumiendo la
hipótesis nula estamos diciendo que es
verdadera entonces nos vamos
tomar un umbral el cual sea más extremo
que este valor es decir que su
probabilidad sea menor al 1% de que
suceda a ver supongamos que tenemos
ciertos eventos tales que la media de
estos eventos esté por aquí es decir que
tengan un porcentaje menor al 1% de
pocura como tenemos una probabilidad
menor entonces en este momento se nos
ocurre rechazar la hipótesis nula
supongamos que esta probabilidad es del
0.5 por ciento es decir que suceda a
nuestro suceso es del 0.5 por ciento y
bueno entonces como tenemos una
probabilidad tan pequeña se nos ocurre
hacer la hipótesis de la falsa es decir
rechazamos la hipótesis nula pero justo
en ese momento estamos cometiendo un
error del tipo 1
porque si la hipótesis nula es verdadera
tenemos un 0.5 de oportunidad de que el
evento ocurra es decir si rechazamos la
hipótesis nula vamos a tener un error
tenemos un 0.5 por ciento de
probabilidad de que ocurra un error del
tipo 1